I also want to someone stealing a
sandwich from Gregg's and when I say the
guy sprinted down the road and the
people in gross might eat Savage and
we're running after him sandwiches I
like my pee hi I'm Daisy Ridley and this
is snack wars vegan edition got a lad
Bible okay anything in that color is
from America super sour double drops
blue raspberry is it a liquid no one
should be spraying anything on anyone
elses now I'm sweating it's really
stressful eating in front of a group of
people but no one else is it you're like
oh it's warm
this one says um I want you this one
says that they do little emoji faces
very nice because you're eating and
getting a little compliment love hearts
pratik UK wins okay so I've got a light
pastry using with golden syrup decorate
it with a glazed pastry lattice and a
pop tart is that good Wow and frosty
this what do you know
[Music]
this is American on clergyman it tastes
like a factory cardboard that was
somehow made edible is really dry and I
had to eat them together because my
mouth is so full of Factory definitely
mr. Kipling
actually had some flavor other than
horrible sores Americans I know you're
passionate about cars that's actually
great delicious know that apple pie I'm
not going to eat this time bye happy in
an apple pie plenty of times I haven't
tried this the thing is Briggs is like a
chain of bakeries but there are really
reasonable I also want so someone's
stealing a sandwich from Gregg's and
when I say the guy sprinted down the
road and the people in gross might eat
Savage and we're running after him
sandwich was our night by P but to be
honest I never went for an apple pie so
actually I wouldn't recommend eating it
all the time that Gregg's okay so
twiglets are from the UK and I've been
your pretzel pieces I'm really hoping
that they're not too pricing and I look
like an absolute wimp oh that's really
nice
well done Snyder's of Hanover I mean I
know it could be let's test delicious
I love Marmite so much oh that's tricky
I'm gonna say this is delicious it's a
new flavor in my mouth
everything's working very well but
twiglets has been a love of mine my
whole life so you Kevin's well I would
say my Oreos they're delicious but they
do contain palm oil I ate the whole
thing
I mean why Avengers richest April of
every single party any child in Britain
went to growing up there was always the
crate but that fake item that was so
delicious there was usually ice cream
and jelly all of them really healthy
snacks that keep hit strong both in them
it's like honesty in a spoonful of sugar
I'm gonna go Oreos they just provided a
little bit like different textures
different receptors UK wins yes
it's very nerve-racking honestly eating
in front of a load of people see I'm not
bloody fingers into
you
[Music]